bonsoir mesdames et
[Applaudissements]
messieursen désolé
Nicole bonsoir je vous en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prie
ce film représente qu'une infime partie
de sa vie il y a d'autres éléments un
peu dramatiques ou mais pour
moi l'essence de Grace Kelly était son
humanité sa lutte intérieure et le fait
qu'elle était une maman une mère une
femme qui voulait continuer sa carrière
vous auriez pu vous avez pu ressentir ça
un jour le fait d'abandonner votre
carrière c'est quelque chose ne plus
être actrice vous auriez pu imaginer ça
vous Nicole
kman oui tout à fait je pourrais
renoncer à ma carrière mais chaque
acteur actrice doit faire face à ces
questions on sait jamais ce qui va se
passer
àavenir du jury est-ce que c'est une
nervosité différente que quand on vient
ici avec un film je disce que être
membre du jury est-ce qu'on est nerveuse
différemment que quand on vient avec un
fil on est pas du tout nerveuse quand on
est avec un film oui c'est extrêmement
stressant là non parce qu'on sait que à
part vous parler ce soir je ne vais plus
jamais vous parler pendant 15 jour donc
ça va être merveilleux à part de ne rien
vous dire ou sourire béâtement à tout le
monde donc dirait bonjour quand même je
vous dirais bonjour Voilà c'est la seule
chose que j'ai le droit de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens honoré d'être présidente du
jury un jury
magnifique à l'occasion de ce 67e
festival de can plus important
encore
[Applaudissements]
voilà Cann toujours avec ce soir en
ouverture du festival la projection très
attendue de Grâce de Monaco un biopique
qui en rappel d'autes sur cette célèbre
famille du rocher les Grimaldi
regardez après Grâce de Monaco
l'histoire de grce Kelly l'actrice
devenue
princesse découvrez un autre biopic sur
une princesse
célèbre un ouragan qui est passé sur moi
l'amour a tout
emporté Marion ctillard est Stéphanie de
Monaco je voulais avoir votre sentiment
sur cette cérémonie alors je je je pense
que je me donne un 6 et demi sur 10
parce qu'en fait c'est tellement
curieusement
impressionnant en cours de route
curieusement on est un petit peu tendu
avant on sait que ça va être un moment
émouvant mais j'ai bien commencé et puis
en cours de route je me suis rendu
compte de ce que j'étais en train de
faire j'ai identifié des gens dans la
salle et j'ai été un petit peu rattrapé
par une émotion en cours de route cela
étant dit c'est un moment incroyable
parce que j'ai dansé avec Nicole Kidman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant good evening my hon declare 6
edition of can International Film
Festival
inaugurated bonsoir c'est un honneur de
déclarer ouverte la 67e édition du
Festival international du film de
[Applaudissements]
Can